Let's pray together over day 29,
surrendering the good and the holy.
Father, we thank you today for the assurance
that you have made us holy and right in your eyes at
the moment of salvation.
We thank you that we are adopted into your family, that we are fully pleasing
to you in a moment of time, that we are acceptable in your sight
and made acceptable by the blood of Jesus Christ through faith
in his atoning sacrifice.
We thank you, Lord, for the assurance that our hearts
and our hands are being made clean
by the blood of Christ, and that we are living in victory over sin, and
that we are walking forward with you.
And Lord, we take these bodies made holy, and
these spirits made holy, and these talents made holy,
and we yield them to you. We surrender to you.
Lord, thank you for accepting our surrender of our rebellion against
you at first.
When we came to you in salvation, thank you for accepting the
surrender that we offered you.
And I ask, Lord, that you would help us to have the courage
to surrender like Jacob and send
away our blessings. Lord, as we do that right now,
we surrender the blessings of life and hands
and feet and mind and talents and voice
and influence and family and
relationships and love and blessings like
finances and house and all these things that are good and
holy. We have yielded them to you. There's nothing wrong with them.
But oh, Lord, we don't wish them to be tainted by
self. We don't wish them to be colored by
self-will or affected by a desire for our own
glory. So we surrender the good to you right now, Lord.
We do this in Jesus' name.
I'd encourage you to continue surrendering things.
Whatever the Lord brings to your mind and your heart,
those things that are good and blessing in your life, surrender them
right now.